hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
the good the bad and the ugly of 45
color panel design
building to higher dimensional flow
cytometry while maintaining biological
resolution
i'm anson blanks of thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
sudden thomas
r d staff scientist at thermo fisher
scientific
all right thanks anson um so
today as anson mentioned i'm going to be
talking about the good the bad and the
ugly of 45 color panel design
and a lot of this is really thinking
about you know as you build
more and more colors how do you maintain
biological resolution
and so you know when i uh initially
started thinking
about really how dies affects your panel
design
you know i had to step back and realize
how much we're actually accounting for
bad dye performance so conventional dyes
really
only perform in two ways and both can
lead to spread you know which is really
loss of theta resolution
and so if you think about the spectral
space you can see here there's a few
um different dyes you can see there's
something like brilliant violet
510 and you can see that that broadly
emits across the violet spectrum but
it's not really cross-excited but it is
using up
some detectors that you might otherwise
be able to use
and then there are other dyes like pe or
pe tandems as well as percy p that are
cross-excited by both the blue and the
yellow green laser
and again that takes up space that you
could use to detect uh biological
markers
if you weren't using up both the blue
and the yellow green spots
and so in addition to that when you're
looking at building out a large panel
you can see here this is showing you a
single color with apc
size 7 and in part a it's showing the
uncompensated
and this is from the university of
chicago blog
looking at you know what is happening in
terms of spread so uncompensated again
you see this
where it looks like pe size 7 would be
also expressed
without the compensation and then part b
is showing ideally
what would happen if you had compensated
properly so you can see
that it looks like you know everything
is expressed in apc size 7
and there's no change in the background
for pe size 7.
but in reality uh what happens is that
there's this compensation
um you know spillover spreading error
and this isn't related really to the
compensation
it's related to you know basically this
um the way that that occurs so in
reality you're still compensating but
you have this
um broader area so if you had for
instance something expressed in pe size
7 which was
um you know not expressed very highly it
would be hard to separate that
biologically whereas if it was bright
you'd be fine so again this affects your
resolution
in addition to all of that um you know
all of these dies that's building to
more and more parameters you think about
how much hardware innovation has
happened
especially really you know in in recent
the recent space
so you know early on there were uh
cytometers like the
facts caliber and then expanding to the
facts advantage with 12 colors and
lsr2 with 18 colors but now with the
advent
of you know something like the fax
symphony which has a number of
detectors off a conventional instrument
and then uh
the bigfoot aurora and id7000 which are
using
spectral cytometry this really is
putting a lot of
pressure you know as you move to more
and more parameters
when you're trying to detect similar
fluorescent labels you actually have to
start dealing a lot more with non-ideal
dive performance than if you can just
position them away
from each other in the spectrum and to
look
more you know in more detail at this
idea of spectral cytometry
um you can see this is just showing you
um two different dyes that have been
acquired on the scitec aurora so you can
see
at top there's apc and uh the other
alexa floor 647 and
generally when you're on a conventional
instrument you would just you know
detect these in a similar channel but
with spectral cytometry you can actually
distinguish the two
um because you're basically taking
advantage of non-ideal dye performance
so
you can see that there are areas where
these are you know
more different from each other when you
get into say parts of the violet
spectrum
or other parts you know as you look
throughout that
but the truth is you know a dye
signature is still this results as
non-ideal dye performance
and so while it will theoretically
increase the number of colors in your
panel
at some point the spread will also get
contributed and so you'll be limited at
what you can actually use
and so one of the first things that we
try to do in looking at
kind of a new system for dye design is
to think about whether
better performing dyes could expand the
number of colors measured
without increased spread and so up top
you can see that there is
you know an imaginary dye called perfect
glue and why is it perfect blue well it
you know is only detected in uh one of
the 64 available detectors
it doesn't uh it's not cross-excited and
you know there's no sort of real decay
it's just you know on or off
and that's not really how it works in in
terms of physics so
you know what you have at the bottom is
a tad less than perfect blue
and so the idea here is that you know
instead of breaking the laws of physics
you still have a very ideal die in that
so you have a bright signal
and then sort of a rapid decline but not
just this sort of on off situation which
would be more of this
you know imaginary die and so you know
one of the things that i have tried to
do is to really understand
how what's happening in spectral
cytometry and if you can design
you know cleaner floors you know what
does that do in terms of this panel
design
and for those of you that may or may not
um
have been to some of the previous talks
that we did under the umbrella of
phytonics
and now having been acquired by thermo
fisher
under the you know thermo fisher
umbrella you can see that this is
taking a originally a 40 color panel
and then looking at where the issues of
spread are removing the dyes
and then building adding in additional
nova floor dyes
with the antibodies conjugated to them
and then testing to see
what happens you know and what you know
what works and what doesn't work
and you know so you know we could get to
these 45 colors
but the real question is what is the
deeper biology and are there places
where
this is actually a problem in terms of
the panel and so the unmixing
uh doesn't quite work the way you know
that we would like it to
and so really trying to get at this idea
of
the good the bad and the ugly and you
can see here you know i have this
image of a stagecoach to kind of think
about
spaghetti westerns they are sort of done
in these serialized ways
and so you know the point of this 45
color panel is not just to say okay well
it's done and there's no more issues
but really to understand better what
works and what doesn't
and i think what doesn't work is
actually you know really helpful for all
of us to understand
what is happening with spectral
cytometry as opposed to conventional
cytometry
and the problem with building to higher
parameters
is both the limit of the detectors
available for the unmixing so
you know even if you have say 64
detectors you need some amount to be
able to detect
changes in in the dies
so you know what are these signatures um
so if you're using more and more of the
detectors that can be an issue
um but also this this idea of increasing
spread so any of sort of
uh problems in in the background of
what's happening with the die
that can contribute overall to the
resolution that you have biologically
and so the goal is to really understand
how pushing towards a theoretical
maximum number of parameters
affects what you do with panel design
and also the resulting biological
resolution
and so um stepping back from that one of
the things
that um we did so
this is showing you the phyton platform
and
what that is is actually a new way to
sort of think about developing dyes
and then testing that out in these
bigger flow panels
and so what you can see is that there is
initially the single stranded dna and
their
donor and acceptor dyes that are on
different strands and then because the
dna has a you know a
sequence specificity and these dyes are
conjugated you can actually control the
distance of the donor and the acceptor
and so this allows to really optically
engineer
and generate dyes that are you know
engineered to have specific excitation
and emission or even increase brightness
by design and you can see here for
instance
uh the top one is showing you a two
cluster version
and right and the bottom version is this
four cluster version
and so what that means is that you can
continue to build out in terms of
brightness and so
um you know then these can then be
attached to antibodies and you can look
at these
labels and so in terms of thinking about
the process of designing those labels
um really had to step back and say what
would the requirements be if you could
start from scratch with a die
so you'd want it to be bright and clean
silent in the violet and really limit
laser cross excitation
you'd want it to be consistent and
stable so if you're using it from one
time to the other
that you don't run into any issues and
ideally you'd like to be able to control
brightness
and so um this is just showing you the
current
uh dies that are available so this is
showing you
basically how we've kind of looked at
targeting so you can see that there are
dies that are excited by the blue the
yellow green and the red
we have not built since the uv and
violet yet but i would say you know stay
tuned for that
and you can see that um in this case
what we've tried to do
is to build along the spectrum sort of
looking at the aurora as a model
in terms of you know how many dyes can
you build
and then also being able to separate out
for instance what's detected off the
blue and the yellow
green since that is an issue for p e and
p
tandems and so
stepping back before going into the 45
color data
i want to talk a bit about how we've
really targeted approaches approaches to
fluorescent label design
so what you can see here for instance um
is that you know one of the things that
i mentioned previously
um is that the blue and yellow green
excitation
doesn't have to you know what you have
with pe and pe tandems
where they're excited by both of those
lasers doesn't have to be true if you
actually
engineer the excitation and emissions so
that's one of the places we've tried to
take a look at
um also uh we're able to engineer the
brightness
and then um a few things that i think
are not something i had spent as much
time thinking about
really building to a longer stoke shift
uh
so understanding how you know as you get
more red shifted dies
how those are more difficult to develop
and but still very important in terms of
being able to use the full spectrum
and understanding how the cytometer
laser power and available detectors
affect eye performance and so just to
start with the first one this is showing
you
um pe dazzle um and nova floor blue 610
and this is not showing you the emission
but rather the normalized uh absorbance
or excitation
so what you can see here is that you
know pe dazzle is
you know a great die in terms of being
bright but if you really think about you
know being able to use both the blue
and the yellow green lasers to excite
that you can see here
that um in the red that this would be
excited off of all of those whereas
something like nova floor blue 610 you
can see
is excited uh primarily off the 488
nanometer laser and not so much off of
the yellow green
whereas nova 4 yellow 610 is excited
primarily by the yellow green laser and
not so much
by the blue laser and so what this does
is allow you to really get this
two-for-one idea so instead of being
having taking up two detectors with
pedazzle you can actually separate those
out
and actually measure two different
markers instead of just one
and there are people that you know say
well i don't really have this issue and
that's because a lot of
designers of instruments have designed
around this problem rather than build
dyes
so say on a portessa there's often a
trigon
and there might be a detector say for
fitzy percy p and then your scatter
but what that the reason that is is
because um
there are a number of p e and p e
tandems that would be excited by both
and so you wouldn't be able to resolve
that but that doesn't mean your
instrument couldn't do that that's just
uh existing performance and so
you know i've talked about um thinking
about the you know the separation of the
blue and the yellow green
but um also remember it's important for
these to be
consistent and stable and so what you
can see here these are showing two
different lots of the nova fours
and uh what's really interesting is that
you know for instance if you look here
at the graph for
nova 4 blue 530 you can see that
um it almost looks like there's just one
line here and these are two different
lots and that's
uh in terms of how similar they are um
from time to time from manufacturing
batch to manufacturing batch
and so they really are consistent and
stable and this is in a lot of ways
because
instead of having say with a pe tandem
die where you have to deal with where
you know
say a side die attaches say if you're
doing pe size 7 it might attach in
different places
and so you have more of that spread
because you're attaching the donor and
the acceptor at specific positions and
you're able to control that that really
changes how
these are consistent and stable in terms
of that
process of testing from watch a lot
in addition if you look at the
antibodies you can see that
uh the nova 4 conjugated antibodies also
really exhibit a
lot to lock consistency and so this is
just showing you a titration
so you can see when you're in you know
the dose range
and then reaching saturation in terms of
the concentration
you can see that even though there's two
different lots the
saturation and all of that is quite
similar in terms of how they perform
so um another thing that we've
looked at because of the phyton platform
is that the nova floor dyes are stable
at room temperature
and so you know the way to test this
what we did is take
antibodies and basically wrap them in
aluminum foil and either
leave them at room temperature or four
degrees and look at how stable
the you know basically the dye is over
that
time period and what you can see here i
like to think about this sometimes as
the absent-minded graduate student
experiment because i certainly have
dealt in my days with you know someone
forgetting leaving the antibody out
and even if you leave it out for these
14 days you really don't see any
differences
between what's happening at room
temperature are four degrees and so
not only are they consistent but you can
see that they're stable over
you know this extended temperature
incubation and so in addition
there's this question of you know okay
if you fix the cells
what happens and if this has
been something that's been tested a lot
with covid
so you know if you can't run your sample
right away and you leave it in fixative
does that change what you see or do you
start getting more background
and you can see here that when you're
looking at fresh cells versus
fixed for 14 days there's really no
differences detected in those samples so
again you know very encouraging in terms
of how
consistent and stable the dies are
and then thinking about engineering
brightness so i mentioned before that
there was
a way where we can add more floors onto
say the existing structure so our normal
uh
phytons which are you know composed the
nova floors
are on these two clusters so basically
two of the four arms
of this um cruciform structure and so
another way that we can also build out
brightness
is actually you know changing somewhat
um
you know the idea of what what dyes are
there
and looking more specifically so if you
take this analogy
of engineering for brightness you
with a light bulb you would have 100
watt 200 watt or 300 watts
in terms of being able to change the
same light and so the same idea of being
able to measure
here so we have the thus far the nova 4
blue 610 at either a 30s or 70s
version and the nova 4 blue 660 at a 40s
or 120s
version and what those are measuring is
actually
measures of the separation index
and so this is really a surrogate for
thinking about brightness
and so you can something that is higher
in terms of
looking at say the 30s version you can
see here
and this is measured on an aurora using
cd4 as the antigen and you can see with
the same antigen you actually have
two different brightnesses for the nova
4 blue 610 and the nova 4 blue 660 um
one thing i want to draw your attention
to is that these are not
exactly the same dies so rather than
build with a two cluster versus four
cluster in this case there are different
component dies and so these
you know are very similar but not
entirely the same so you can see the
similarity index
which would give you that idea um so
it's not one
which would mean they're the same but
rather 0.97 and 0.96
so you could actually you know add this
dimensionality in terms of
non-co-expressed markers and be able to
look at those that way another great
challenge that
we've really been building towards is
thinking about
a long stoke shift from the defined
primary laser and so when you look at
this you can see that there's the
primary laser
that's then exciting the donor die and
then you know there's this high spectral
overlap and so it's very easy to see how
you could have something that is being
excited say from the blue laser
and then there's this donor and you
actually get
emission further down the spectrum but
as you build out to more and more
brightness
so you can see here at the bottom you
still have that donor but now you don't
have that overlap
so in terms of getting to a more
red-shifted die
and getting this you know fluorescence
it's more of a problem
than i think a lot of us spent spend
time thinking about
and one of the examples i want to show
here is just where you can see that when
you look at say the yellow green there's
this gap between yg5
and yg9 uh when you look at the red this
is
r4 between r4 and r8 and again those are
just
sort of jumps in terms of the detectors
and so building to these places where
they're more red shifted
is you know a bit of a challenge and so
one of the things that we really wanted
to try to attack with the system that we
have
and so if you think about this um you
know the goal
um in terms of this long stoke shift
from a defined primary laser
is a bit uh like when you're throwing
the football across the field in
american football um so you can see here
you know if you're thinking about going
that shorter distance it doesn't take
nearly the effort in terms of the throw
it doesn't take nearly the effort in
terms of catching it
and that's really what we're doing is
taking this long distance across the
spectrum
and you know trying to avoid any
cross-excitation
and then um ultimately what you're
dealing with is that the acceptor
um a lot of these size 7 being an
example
it's larger and tends to be more
unstable so susceptible to oxidation so
really
building out dyes that are consistent
and can
you know actually do this red shifting
and allow you to use more of the
spectrum
is pretty important in terms of thinking
about dye design
the other thing um is that dye
performance is really related to the
instrument configuration
so a lot of work we've done as i used
the
the scitec aurora spectral cytometer as
you know the readout but what you can
see here is that there are the five
lasers if you have that instrument
and um these can really range in terms
of
um you know what is the excitation um
you know so for instance there's the you
know 20 milliwatt uv laser and then you
go up to the 100 milliwatt
violet laser and i'm just showing you
right down below
that really when you look at a lot of
different cytometers that even have
lasers of these wavelengths you can see
that there's a lot of differences
in terms of you know what what you tend
to see and this is just
just taking a few uh cytometers
including
you know saying a tune um a fortessa um
a few others and really say okay what's
happening here
um and then also i guess when you think
about the aurora
it's interesting in that the signature
that you're going to see in terms of the
diet performance still is going to be
slightly different than another
instrument not only because
of the laser power that you have but
also
thinking about apds which is just
similar in a way to detect the photons
so you can see that apds are
detect better in the red and that's what
the aurora uses for the system whereas
pmts detect better
in the uv and the violet and so um when
you're looking at designing for say two
different instruments
and in this case you can see that um
you know if you think about for instance
the bigfoot um spectral sorter
that it's a very different setup and so
designing for the same
um you know designing to make limit
cross-excitation and also
brightness uh can affect this process so
the the bigfoot has
these hundred milliwatt lasers across
the spectrum and it does have
if you go to the seven laser
configuration you have these additional
lasers
and so really thinking about you know if
you're designing for die performance
where is the cross-excitation and does
the brightness of some of these
affect that process so one of the things
that
we have depending on which instrument
you use is something like the nova blue
660 the original
40s version there are places where it
actually can look brighter in the red
and again that varies from instrument to
instrument because
of the fact that you know there's again
this better detection in the red off of
the apd's on the aurora specifically
as compared to other instruments and so
um the signature really is going to be
related to the instrument and
thinking about the dye performance um
that's you know really important to
as you know we are designing new dies to
really say okay does this work for this
instrument or
even think about whether we should
design something different for
a different sort of instrument um and so
taking a step back from all of that
thinking about what's happening with
panel design
um and so now i've talked a lot about
different dies and what they do
what you can see here is you know a
number of issues that you're
contemplating even if you're not
you know thinking about how that is all
working together
so there's you know the issue of
spectral overlap a lot of times we're
dealing with that with compensation and
sometimes
that is sufficient and other times you
um can also have spillover spreading
errors where you actually
affect you know how much you can
actually detect so
you know have you lost the resolution
and so these dimmer markers can't be
detected
um matching up antigen density to
say you know if you have a highly
expressed antigen
versus a lower expressed antigen
matching that brightness so you
for a lower expressed antigen you want
to make sure you have a
more highly a brighter dye and
vice versa so these are all things that
kind of go on in the background in terms
of thinking about
designing your optimal panel and so
as you're building to more and more
colors um spillover is really the enemy
and if you think about the range of
detection you know there are issues
with electronic noise autofluorescence
but spread is the main thing that really
affects
what you can detect and you can see here
at the top just to remind you
of this idea that for instance in this
case even with a single color
p6 apc size 7 it's actually affecting
what you can detect
off of the pe size 7 and so it's acting
as the perpetrator
and pe site 7 becomes the victim and if
you have something bright enough that
you're detecting off the pe size 7
that may not be an issue but if you're
trying to detect something dimmer that
can be an issue
and you can see below this is just
showing uh two different noble floor
dies and that there is not
in adjacent channels on the itunes and
you can see there's really not
so much of the silver spreading error
that you're seeing in this particular
case
and so um you know in previous talks
i have shown data where we built to 40
colors
using the aurora backbone panel
and so they had built to 35 colors and
in that case this is before they
published their 40 color work
and so one of the things early on that i
wanted to test was
you know what is happening when you look
at
you know say that 40 color panel where
are the issues
and then you know if you try to increase
that to 45 colors how do you do that in
a way to really think about what's
happening
and so what you can see here um in the
so basically taking that you know
original 35 color panel removing one of
the
labels that was not commercially
available so 34 colors
and then taking that to 40 colors and
then looking
at you know some of the places where
there were issues so um
in this case bb515 and 50
there were some issues once you added
nova or blue 530 they're already 0.98
similar so that was a place of an issue
issue
and then really looking at some of the
other places so as i
you know look forward in terms of
removing dyes to lower the spread you
can see here again i mentioned that
just by removing the brilliant blue 515
you can see that
you've reduced a lot of the spread into
um
you know the 50 channel and what this
really is saying is
you know what is the sort of background
that starts to creep up that affects
what you can actually detect there
and so you know when that's decreasing
the change in the spectral spread
that means that you should be able to
gain more resolution in that process
and so the other two places that i
targeted were
was the bv510 and again that
you know because it spreads more
throughout the violet spectrum it did
help some
um but more across the spectrum and not
so much in one specific place
another thing that um i removed was the
c4568
and you can see again that there's this
decrease in the spread
um you know so you're able to actually
detect a number of the floors better off
of the yellow green
that are excited by the yellow green
laser and so
to really identify then the next
perpetrator die to build to 45 colors
you can see here in this case pe sci-5
is the next target that you would use
because you can see how
this has you know this is now not
looking at so much the change in spread
but overall what's happening
in terms of you know the overall spread
of the panel um
and so you can see where that's more of
an issue and so having removed those
four dies then
the idea is that i wanted to test um 10
additional nova 4 labeled antibodies
in a 45 plus color panel
and so just to step back in terms of how
we did that process
what you can see here is that there are
you know different antibodies
um and then these are the different nova
floors there and so if you wanted to see
what the spectra was for any of the nova
floors
that i'm talking about you can look at
the thermo fisher
spectral viewer as well as floral finder
or fp bass and there's also the scitec
full spectrum viewer
so in terms of saying okay how similar
are these dyes or not
to each other and so the um
this is showing you uh one of the things
that we tried to do to understand about
designing into that panel
and showing the separation index for the
nova floors so again this idea of
measuring the brightness um as well as
thinking about the spread
and so something like brilliant blue 515
is you know get is a brighter dye
and will give you more separation index
but it also has more spread
and so that will affect you know what's
happening in your overall panel
and the thing i would say is that really
what you want to think about in terms of
panel design
is putting the floor in that gives you
the separation that you need
but you don't need the brightest thing
if if you're not taking advantage of
of that so really matching up closely
okay do i need something brighter here
or something dimmer
um and you know what has given me the
biological resolution that i want
and here this is just showing you a few
more of the nova floors
and you can see the ones that are
excited by the yellow green laser
um so these are primarily excited by the
561 alone
as opposed to the pe and pe tandems
where they're excited by
both the 488 and the 561 so starting to
take up more of those detectors in your
panel
and then um one of the things that we
try to do
and this is also on the thermo fisher
website is have these available so that
you can really say
okay if i've already got a panel you
know what does the separation index
look like um and could i for instance be
able to take advantage of this process
um and you know switch to say anova
floor and open up
another detector or do i really need
that brightness because this is such a
dimly expressed antigen so understanding
that process better
and then this last slide is just showing
you what we have available
at this point um off of the red laser as
well and again i mentioned that
uh we're still building in the future to
the violet and the ultraviolet
and so in terms of looking uh what i
showed you in a panel we
literally went through what you know we
actually used for the custom conjugation
process
and so here what you can see is that
um to do this um what we did was
conjugate an oligo
um single stranded oligo to the antibody
purify that antibody and then leverage
uh the one-to-one phyton to antibody
labeling
to determine the antibody concentration
and the precise concentration
of before dye required and so with this
customs process what we do
is actually remove any unlabeled
antibody and therefore
um you actually get this one-to-one
labeling and so you can attach
uh the novo four die and not have any
excess
of that you know around or unlabeled
antibody that will compete with
the other parts and so when you're
looking at
you know the requirements for submitting
this
generally we would prefer to have
greater than one mg per ml of antibody
to start with and pbs with no azide but
these can be concentrated or buffer
exchanged that's not really an issue
the main thing to be aware of in a
custom conjugation is that
any stabling stabilizing proteins would
be labeled in that process
and um so that is actually could be an
issue if there was a problem for
background
um and then you know we can actually do
these customs
um in-house and we actually require a
little more antibody
um so for the if the customer's
providing the antibody this would be
starting with at least one milligram of
antibody um
or if you want to look at the final
concentration in that amount we recover
about 40 percent and the idea is because
we're removing the unlabeled antibody
you need more antibody to start with
but it does give you a somewhat brighter
signal for the same
issue so in terms of thinking about the
currently available
antibody conjugates these are the ones
that we have available
so you know we have five in the mouse
and seven
in the human and these are available on
all of the
nova floor dies so we have
15 that were released up until now and
uh now as of
in july we're actually releasing the
additional four
colors so every color can be found for
every antibody so you can really mix and
match
what you're using um and then last
just to bring this up before we go back
into the panel
we also have conjugation kits so if you
wanted to say had 100 micrograms of
unlabeled antibody and want to attach
nova 4 there's actually a fairly simple
process to be able to do this
and so again this follows a similar
pattern to what we have in our customs
program so you can attach the single
stranded nova four linker to the
antibody
and then in this case there's just these
two pipetting steps after you buffer
exchange
then you can add the activation reagent
and attach
the single stranded linker the second
step is to actually precipitate and
remove
any excess single-stranded linker and
attach the note before die
and then the third step is to actually
mix
this oligo labeled antibody with the
nova floor in the particular color that
you want
and then you just mix them together and
wait overnight and they will anneal at
four degrees overnight
and what this does is also allow you for
instance if you bought more than one
conjugation kit
you can actually leave it at this step
after you've removed any excess linger
and actually you know match up two
different colors if you wanted if you
had
you know two different nova floors you
can just make as much as you need
at that time of the conjugate and so
that's really helpful in terms of
as i was even designing this panel and
testing some things there were
some that weren't bright enough um in
terms of separation i needed for that
particular antibody so i could mix and
match
pretty rapidly to think about that and
we are building to more antibodies being
available so i would say
you know stay tuned that's one of the
most exciting things about joining
thermo fisher is that
we actually have that ability now and so
um going back to the panel you can see
that in this case what i did
again was you know take out the
problematic
dyes and antibody combinations and then
replace them
with nova floors and add more into the
panel to really detect
you know this broad immune panel and
then
really looking in depth at you know
what's happening um so this is
the spectral spread matrix
and uh you can see this is the the
column sum so you can actually see
where the places that actually have the
most
problems in terms of the detection and
one of the places
the resolution was lost most uh
unsurprisingly somewhat you know because
there is
for instance only um there are eight
detectors off of the red laser
you can see that um apc and nova flora
red 660
have a lot of spread and probably alexa
force 647
contributes to this because you have
these sort of three dies that are in
this very close proximity
and when i was originally designing this
panel we had not at that point you know
didn't have the similarity indices for
these particular dies so
i really wanted to see what happened and
what you can see is that
um you know all of these are actually
very similar when you look
at their spectra and in fact nova red
660
is 0.98 similar to alexa floor 647
and so likely having these three
together affects what you have in the
process
and so um then thinking ahead
um so one of the things i would
recommend is actually
you know saying okay maybe we don't
include no before red 660 here
and not just use the apc and alexa for
647
in this case and then really looking at
other targets
one of the most exciting things to see
was
how what how little spread there was
across
a lot of the blue laser excited dies
and so um one of the things i want to
draw your attention to
is that part of this happened um
actually
in the way that when you're building out
a 45 color panel the
we turned out we had ordered an antibody
and it hadn't arrived in terms of being
able to do the experiment
so i had to leave that out but this
ended up being fortunate because you
really didn't have some of the issues
that you might have otherwise
and so when you look at this um bb 515
and novo nova 4 blue 510
are actually you know um one 1.0
similar when you look at their actual
spectra they're not exactly the same but
what this means is that they really
can't be unmixed in a very good way
and even the fitzy to bb 515 is a
pretty difficult and mixing so 0.98
similar
but in terms of looking at these nova 4
blue 510
and nova 4 blue 530 are actually the
least similar and so this makes
makes uh reduces the spread and allows
you to use
more of the detectors across this range
um
in addition uh to looking at sort of
what was happening across the blue laser
i wanted to look more closely at what's
happening off the yellow green
and so i mentioned before you could see
that the spread was quite increased with
te cy5 and that was likely because the
pe ci5
is actually detected in two places that
are very similar
um so where nova floor blue 660 and nova
4 blue
or sorry i know before yellow 660 are
detected so again
you know you could detect um pe psi5 off
of either of those but since
you're using both of those spaces that
can affect the spread
and so even though the
where you're seeing more of the spread
is in nova 4 yellow 610
i would suspect that that's in part due
to pe dazzle
where it would normally be detected off
of the you know blue
or the yellow green but not necessarily
um both at the same time and so that
also is likely affecting that that
process and so p e
p basil in this case might be the next
thing to target to remove
and the last uh thing in terms of
thinking about this is
you know is the nova 4 red 660 removal
sufficient to remove spread off of red
laser um
and if not you know it's probably worth
looking at
um you know removing one more die from
this region to really reduce the spread
and so um what you can as you're looking
then at the panel
again i already mentioned we've removed
the dies that affected the resolution
off of the 40 color panel
built in this case to 45 colors
and then you can see that
you know one of the first
recommendations would be to remove
the cd 141 nova 4 red 660 to open up
what's happening in the red
then to in this case because i wasn't
using the cd57 and fitzy
you could actually move that uh off of
nova 4 blue 585
and separate that more um and then not
create that again that bunching that
happens
um with bb5150 and
you know 530 and 10. um
and so last removing
the pe dazzle um as i mentioned this
should also decrease spread you can move
that to the nova 4 blue
555 so this is what i would propose in
terms of actually getting to
a better panel with reduced spread and
so
um you can see that you know here
so now you've moved cd 24 over there
and so in this case what i've done is
taken cd44
from where it was on nova 4 blue 585
cd 141 away from
the you know for red 660 and then taken
cd 80 which was previously at nova 4
blue 555
and taking those from the panel and you
still end up with a 43 color panel
and so again it's really about thinking
about
what you know what are you hoping to see
and
understand biologically and so
continuing to build
this process and so that's why i
mentioned you know to be continued idea
so really thinking
critically about what's happening
and so overall stepping back from the
specifics of this particular panel
you know if the goal is to really build
a high parameter panel
we still really the goal is really also
to build a low spread immune panel
without sacrificing the biological
resolution
and so in terms of critical thinking
around panel design
one of the things hopefully you've been
able to see in this talk is that
spectral cleanliness is more important
than brightness
for high parameter analysis and so you
know as you get cleaner
especially cleaner dies you can actually
use you know
use more of your detectors and really
open up what you can see
that as i've gone through iterative
panel design
is critical to remove spread and work
towards higher dimensional biological
analysis
and so really thinking about you know
okay
you know have i built the best possible
panel or are there places where i really
need to look closer at spread
and improve what i'm able to resolve
biologically
so i would say you know building any of
these panels is a process of really
thinking critically about matching
you know the antigen with you know again
the brightness that you need so not
using more brightness than you need
which can increase spread in other areas
of the panel so
in the spread is really you know what's
happening off of the non-primary
detector
and so thinking about you know
continuing to improve that panel
is really important and then also you
can really utilize the blue and the
yellow green detectors
in a way that you haven't before in some
of these cases
because you're building around the
cross-excited dyes with the p
e and p e tandems instead of saying okay
well we can't use that detector and we
have to use something else here really
thinking about getting this
two for one idea off of one floor
um and so in the end it's not about how
many colors
that you're able to detect but the
resolution of the underlying biology
that matters
and so i just want to emphasize that
because i think it's easy to get caught
up in the idea of building
some more colors and being able to
detect all these things but if you don't
have the resolution
then you really don't have you know good
science and that's what's really
important whether that's a
on a conventional cytometer or a
spectral cytometer
and so um just really thinking about you
know not just the specifics of this but
rather you know how how can we continue
to build better panels where we're
getting the biology that we're
interested in understanding
and so with that um i'd like to thank
everyone
for attending uh the talk and open up
the floor to any questions that anyone
might have
um anson will be the moderator
and can help um you know we can discuss
any questions that you might have
so thanks so much for your attention
thank you seddon for your informative
presentation uh we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
i just click on the ask ask a question
box located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so we've already got a few questions so
we'll get started
the first question um says i use
edu click it which quickit kit which has
a fixed
perm and a catalyst induced reaction i
see major shift
in major shift to the right when i gate
for cd4
and cd8 they appear compacted with this
kit
how to how did the nova floors work
after
fixed perm great question
um and this is one of the places where
we need to actually do the experiments
to test it out
um so i think in terms of
the specifics of the kit that just
basically these two things need to be
brought together
and tested but in terms of
you know i think labeling the excess
cell
like so if you're labeling extracellular
and then doing a fix and perm
um that you know seems to work well
with the nova floors uh there is um
i don't think you're doing it in this
case but if you were
permeabilizing and doing intracellular
there are some additional blocking steps
at that point but that wouldn't
be what you're talking about in terms of
this particular kit so great question
um just need to do more experiments on
that
right so i think we may need a little
more clarification on this one
um but how does this how does this
affect the diagnosis for patients
uh cd markers hiv dosing for rh
immunoglobulin okay yeah so i'll just
try to
speak in general to the concept i mean i
think you know
one thing that spectral cytometry is
really useful for
is thinking about limited samples um
i know that i actually used to do some
hiv research
and one of the things that you're
dealing with sometimes is if you have a
question and you have longitudinal
samples it is really helpful to be able
to use more markers
to really look at what's happening and
so
understanding that when you only have
say one
you know one or two tubes left and it's
very precious
i think that actually is a place where
spectral cytometry is going to play
continue to play a big role hiv cancer
things like that
um and then i guess um in terms
uh so so feel free um to
throw another question if i'm not
answering this so i'm just kind of
thinking about what you know things
might be there um
i think you know one of the things
that's important
and you know being able to use your
sample fully with spectral is important
but also making sure that the panel is
really you know well well designed
and that you're not picking up something
that you know may be and
say an artifact if if you have um
say spread or something like that into
the channel so i think
sort of the two ways you really are able
to be able to use more of your sample
but you may have to take more time
designing say these bigger panels but
once you do that
um it should be good to use and
something i didn't get into this talk
during this talk but also just you know
being able to look at that many
parameters and setting up
you know okay you know is this working
and i think one of the still the
barriers going forward will be
developing you know say master mixes or
things like that when you think about
staining with 30 or 40 colors that
certainly is an issue just to make sure
that
you have you know when you're doing the
spectral cytometry you are having to do
all your controls
um at that same time or at least make
sure the instrument is consistent
so
um do you have any specific thoughts
about some of the more recent pe
and apc conjugates and how they interact
with nova floors
for example p fire 600 or atc
fire 810 yeah well
uh you know in in both of those what you
can see is that
uh they're they're focusing on a similar
type of problem which is getting
to this red-shifted area where there
just aren't a lot of
dyes in that area so obviously a really
important thing to address
um you know in terms of getting into
this space where you aren't
actually using up some of the spectrum
and getting there um
so you know i think in terms of pe fire
600
you do have again this issue with the uh
the
you know blue yellow green split so in
terms of the nova floors
um i'm going to have to think about what
wavelength that is at but if
you know if there are nova forces there
you can actually you know be able to use
that two-for-one
issue with it that's spectral or
otherwise um
and so the other the other thing i think
these are
um you know good in terms of reaching
that
um further part of the spectrum they are
bright so sometimes they will
have some off target you know prospect
citation
or otherwise but i don't think there's
really any issues in terms of using them
in a panel
so as long as you're getting the
resolution that you need and not
introducing
spread you should be able to use those
in a panel
together so hopefully that addresses
your question
and great questions please keep them
coming
do dna based dyes have it have an effect
on dna binding reagents
yes yes they do um really good question
so
we recommend using fixable viability
dyes
with nova floors and anson and i early
on
actually spent some time troubleshooting
when someone had some issues staining
because
unfortunately a dye like daffy 7ad
perfidium iodide
they will bind to the dna you know
structures because they are dna
intercalating dyes
and so if you can use um either
some of the um the calcium based
viability dyes
or the
live dead some of those um basically
those will bind and you know to the cell
and not be the dna intercalating but you
really can't use those together
and if you did use those what happens is
it either quenches or alters the
fluorescence
so we spent some time troubleshooting
that so that is definitely an issue that
you need to be aware of
here's a really good question about
purple rain when are you planning to
introduce 405 nanometer probes
um i will say that it's definitely a
work in progress and something that
um it's pretty exciting for me because
one of the things i get to do
and anson um you know also you know does
some work
uh looking at these but um
basically we do a lot of the die vetting
and so part of the process
is you know testing is this diet does
this diet either brighter
or have less spread than things that are
existing so i will tell you that those
experiments
are in progress and there are some
interesting candidates
but just say stay tuned we're definitely
working there
are there any ways of combining cell
cell
cycle analysis or measurement of dna
content with the staining
art with staining with nova force
such a good question and something that
um
i certainly have spent some time
thinking about and i know that
uh sean burroughs who you know has also
worked
on the dye design side one of the things
we've tried to think about
so i think it is an open question i
don't have an answer
now but i'm certainly one of it's one of
the things that
we're really interested in is whether
you know there can be a way to kind of
balance it out currently there's not a
great way to sort of use an
intercalating dye
that you would be using in cell cycle
analysis you could use things like
um say ki 67 but i think in terms of
probably what you're really asking
i think that still is part of the next
frontier there are i think some other
cell cycle dies and that's one of the
things i really want to kind of look at
is see if there are other dyes that can
be used with noaa floors there but
in terms of intercalating dyes unless we
find a way to kind of shield the
structure
that's that's just going to continue to
be an issue
but great question
all right so we've got more time so if
anybody has any
more questions please continue to drop
those into the q
a box um
can you tell me what the the size of the
phyton is
yeah so it's 20 nanometers across so
um it's not exactly flat but in terms of
that sort of curved
curved surface if you think about the
cruciform structure
and it's about 150 kilodaltons
so it's actually uh somewhat smaller
than pe
which is i think around 220 or 250
kilodaltons
um but yeah
so can you tell me a little bit more
about the the structure of the nova
floors
uh are they tandem dyes right
it's it's a really good question so when
you think about
you know the the nova floor structure um
what it is it gives you really this
ability to position
very precisely um your donor and
acceptor dies
and because they're actually conjugated
at a specific point of the dna
they are precisely placed so on one
level
um you can think about you know a tandem
as being a dye
where you know these are put placed in
certain positions to allow threat to
happen with the donor and acceptor
and so you know that's true but the but
the you know most tandem dies you have
to conjugate
um this directly and can't really
control you know where the donor and
acceptor are or
sometimes how many there are say if you
think about pe size seven or something
like that
you you know may attach at different
places and have different
numbers of those so you really don't get
that consistency and stability from time
to time using them and so
we sort of think about this is really
just a different
type of structure because uh what you
find with nova floors because they are
at these specific
points in terms of the donor and
acceptor
and where they're positioned they're
actually very repeatable
and they seem to be a lot more stable
than a lot of the existing tandems
that are out there so i would say it's a
different class of dye
one of the things that was mentioned was
cell blocks
um is that an fc block
really yeah good question so cell blocks
is not
an fc block and it's also not the same
as a you know super bright
um or any of the brilliant binding
buffers which prevent interactions
between dyes what it does is actually
prevent
non-specific binding of dyes uh to the
cells the cells will actually
can sometimes bind to uh the dyes
and so that's what it actually does is
interfere with that
all process looks like we have time for
one more question
um as i understand correctly you are
looking into spreading the nova floors
into the violet spectrum
do you think that scientists get more
out of novaphores
instead of super brights or brilliance
yeah it's a it's a good question i mean
i think the point is that
hopefully as we do expand that uh what
we're trying to look
at is what uh dyes are currently out
there so
trying to say okay does it have a
cleaner spectrum
or you know are we getting to something
that's you know brighter and more
specific
um sort of trying to look at both of
those before releasing them so one of
the great things about the platform is
we can test a number of things
um and so what i would say is you know
by the time we are you know looking at
that we are also comparing that to the
super brights of the brilliance
the other thing is that um in some of
these cases
um you know if you are dealing with a
really bright dye and don't have
you know much separation say the
transcription factor
i think you know origami is a good you
know example you know where you just
have a very small
shift even when you have cells that are
specific and so sometimes you need that
brightness
um and so that was i would say sort of
it's balancing what you need
in your spectra i'm sorry in your panel
um in terms of do you really need you
know separation of something that has
very little antigen density
or you know do you really want that
cleanness because you're building out
uh the brighter you know this sort of
bigger panel and
um so we do try to compare it and say
okay
is this particular nova floor how does
this compare to what's out there at that
part of the spectrum
all right i'll sneak one last question
in because i know the answer is going to
be very short
have you tested some of your 40 plus
nova floor panels on
the sony id 7000
not yet i would love to i would love to
get access to an instrument
um so that's you know it's always
exciting to try to
test one of those things but currently i
don't have access to a sony id7000 so
hopefully at some point that would be
something we could test
thank you sudden do you have any final
comments for our audience
i just want to say thanks so much for
coming and these are fantastic questions
so i really appreciate the engagement
and uh you know conversation back and
forth with all the questions so
thanks so much for attending thank you
again seddon for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roofs and our
sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration the this
webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye